hey thanks for coming so first I just
want to thank the organizers I'm really
honored to be on stage at such an
amazing conference it's been a real
pleasure and also I just want to thank
the diversity scholarship sponsors I
actually came here last year on a
diversity scholarship so it means yeah I
means a lot to me that I'm on stage now
so yeah thank you everyone involved you
guys did great hey diversity claps okay
so hi my name is Abbi um I actually did
not change my name to get my job I don't
know if you saw ya aliens talk yesterday
that was amazing I have a newfound
respect for the power of my name and the
privilege I've been given so that was
yeah that blew me away but um yeah I
work for Mozilla and I want no I used
the web to move science forward actually
just changed at you say I want to use
the web to science for it but I realized
this whole talk is me inviting you to
join me so I should probably say that I
am doing that now so yes please join me
and that's what I will talk about for
the next 40 minutes so i work at Mozilla
and we're building a better internet
promoting openness innovation and
opportunity on the web and I came to
Mozilla because I was really interested
in how they were applying this mission
to a very specific area of practice with
science and they have a lot of really
interesting problems in science so
here's the quiz who can tell me what's
similar between these two problems sony
PSP video game graphics and de novo
sequences Embley any ideas yeah that's
what we pale actually yeah that's that
is she I wasn't thinking that but you
and a sticker come find me later yeah
that's true um no I sir I threw this in
last minute because I think it's a
really cool story but they both want
algorithms that really push the limit of
the memory that's available to them so
with the video game graphics um yeah
this is a story actually of um Jared
Simpson he's a principal investigator at
the Ontarians suit for cancer research
where I used to work I I didn't run this
by him that I was going to tell his life
story so I hope that's okay with him
ask for forgiveness later but he was a
video game developer at entertainment
arts and he was writing names for the
PSP and he was making these crazy worlds
with shadows and 3d graphics and fitting
them all to use 64 megabytes of memory
then you heard about this problem that
we have in genomics with de novo
sequences Embley so I don't have a slide
to demonstrate what this looks like so
you're gonna have to use the power of
your imagination sort of understand how
it works but so DNA atcg are these bases
and that goes on for 3 billion 3 billion
and a half base pairs that's your whole
sequence so we used to sequence or like
read the DNA by just going one at a time
saying first a then T then G and so
forth they found that was way faster if
you copy this whole three billion a
genome just copied a bunch of times then
cut it up randomly into tiny pieces and
then just in parallel read each one of
those maybe like a hundred base pair
long sequences and then just let the
computer handle it later so the assembly
is that assembly part where the computer
has to figure out an all these tiny 100
parts and turned into the three billion
genome that we have so back back when
Jared was yeah writing video games he
heard about this problem and the amount
of memory we were using was really
limiting how much analysis we could do
so he's like oh I know how to write
algorithms that use very little memory
so that's what got him interested there
and now he's a cancer researcher so mmm
yeah the point of this story is you guys
have skills that are really useful in
science and I'm going to talk about a
few problems that I think about often um
yeah it's kind of weird with the mic
okay you can hear me right yeah I'm more
nervous than I thought I'd week okay so
one problem um I used to work on is
visualizing protein interactions and
open worm data to help us understand
human diseases so there's lots of open
worm data around and that can help us
understand life in general another
problem is giving you teasers right now
analyzing open genetic data to better
understand how virus and bacteria
interact so that's ecoli up
there but yeah we have we have lots of
open data we need to analyze another one
um is collecting curating open astronomy
datasets to facilitate data analysis and
discovery I through this one in because
i really think stars are cool and I
thought it's cool feature I do not know
anything about astronomy but they also
have data problems so yeah these are
usually tackled by academics sometimes
with very little computing backgrounds
and again I think you guys are the
people who know how to solve these
problems so this talk is really about
open science i know i titled it the
democracy democratization of science i
think that's one of the outcomes of open
science i'm really excited to tell you
all how you can get involved in this
movement but first what does open even
mean so we see this word thrown a lot
there's open source open access data
standards government science and i think
it's starting to lose some of its value
at least for me it is like over time it
just is just another word um i think
when i first heard the word open science
i thought it meant like free science
like for use in speech it just made no
sense to me but um I want to spend a
little bit of time just looking back see
how this term came to inspire so many
movements and sort of get some that
power and meaning back into the word
open so I would argue that a lot of the
fundamental ideas behind openness today
actually originates in Deshawn science
so welcome to the Scientific Revolution
that's King Louie the 14th and it's the
Royal Academy of Sciences being
presented to him but around this time
the Scientific Revolution there was a
lot of discoveries happening and they
realized they needed a platform to share
and collaborate on research if they
wanted to keep moving human knowledge
forward so in came the first academic
journal devoted to science the
philosophical transactions of the royal
society so in case that's confusing
philosophical was natural philosophy
which is roughly equivalent to science
today but the Royal Society of London
established that and this guy Henry
oldenburg he was their first secretary
so he actually wrote a series of letters
which gives us a bit of insight into why
he created the first journal for science
so here's a quote from him we must be
very careful as well of registering the
person in time of any new matter as the
matter itself whereby the honor of the
invention will be reliably preserved to
all posterity so that makes sense you
need to write things down and give
people credit for it so we can build on
that a couple other quotes from him I'll
ingenious men and i would add and women
and other people there too that's ok
he's oldenburg is a different time I'll
engine is none will thereby be
encouraged to impact their knowledge and
discoveries he's encouraging people to
share what they've learned so that we
can iterate on it and then participation
being first revised by some of the
members he understood that more eyes
make things better and when more people
see it yeah we have better results so
science really embraced a culture of
working together and sharing discoveries
to further human knowledge so we learn
things about astronomy I don't actually
know what this teaches about astronomy
Beth I was a really cool gift we
understand how white blood cells chase
after bacteria I was gonna eat it soon
oh that's so cool and those are the red
blood cells we understand that the human
body is so cool and this one I has a
special spot in my heart sized to work
on unwyrm basic studied C elegans so
this is the first multicellular species
ever completely sequence and we know the
genome for it and so many people have
studied this and to understand life like
we understand how this goes from one
cell to the exact 980 something cells so
we know its entire development we've
mapped out the entire neural network so
a lot of people use this organism to
study life and a lot of people share the
data that they have there which is
really great for science so fast forward
to today now that we have the web and
free software there's a new meaning of
open I think so some ideas about about
working open started to come around the
90s so eric raymond published an essay
and i found this picture on flickr i
thought was really cool i didn't read
all the words though so i'm not sure if
it's accurate but evolve just an essay
called the Cathedral in the bazaar where
he compared two different methods of
working on free software so first was
the Cathedral where select grew
of people would build something together
and then in the end release it so
cathedral still a public space but only
some people have a say in what happens
he compared that to a bizarre I've
actually never been to a bizarre so um I
think this is how they work but anyone
can go in to set up a shop you can
negotiate your price the way you
participate in bizarre is very different
than in the cathedral so he was saying
that the bazaar where people have a say
and can do things that was more like
what was happening in Linux so I'm going
to read a quote from the essay he says
Linus Torvalds style of development
release early and often delegate
everything you can and be open to the
point of promiscuity came as a surprise
no quiet reverent cathedral building
here rather the Linux communities seem
to resemble a great babbling bizarre of
different differing agendas and
approaches out of which a coherent and
stable system could seemingly emerge so
he saw this bizarre knee saw that it was
better more eyes made it better and more
people participating yeah something came
out of it so this essay actually
inspired the release of the Netscape
Browser sweet as free software which was
the basis of the Mozilla project who I
work for now and then actually sparked
the label open source so Mozilla if you
guys remember the early 2000s where I II
was just dominating the browser market
Missoula was able to bring together some
people on this tiny open source project
and create something that really
disrupted the market and changed how we
interact with the web so Mozilla likes
to embrace the idea of working open not
just in software but in everything we do
so this is the definition from our wiki
that working open is public and
participatory this requires structuring
efforts that Outsiders can meaningfully
participate and become insiders as
appropriate and I think that at one
point this was true for science anyone
could really participate and take a part
of these discoveries that were going on
it's a little different in science today
so this is my fictional example it's not
at all based on any of my friends in
science but so this is Greta the grad
student I'm great at naming my fictional
people by the way she goes to strange
leave University
and she studies this bacteria called
strange asleep I I think people do
functional programming when they're
infected I don't know okay anyways she
wants to study this bacteria from a
population in West Africa so she gets
some samples I'm not not sure how you
get them um she had them somehow but now
it's time to sequence it so read the DNA
that's behind in and she got 250 strains
in that population it's at around one
hundred dollars per strange she spends
$25,000 sequencing all that but then she
has this one special strain as we buy
sdl which she wants to really understand
better so if you remember when I was
talking about sequencing earlier how
they chop up the genome and then read it
so there's a special sequencer now
PacBio where they chop it up but now the
reads are like seven thousand bases long
instead of just a hundred so that's more
expensive though so she spends five
thousand dollars on that once trained to
do it so now she has a ton of data she's
sequenced a lot she knows the DNA and
she's pretty happy so she goes to her
first meeting nestle by international
meeting he's a lot of people studying
this bacteria she needs some other
people I'm not sure why they all look
alike but woman in stem yay good job
Greta my Greta discovers that two other
research groups they also sequence the s
we buy stl string using that special
pacbio so they're they're using the same
data but that means there was at least a
ten thousand dollar savings they could
have had if they had shared their data
and plus the cost of the pacbio machine
itself that's like seven hundred
thousand dollars although the
university's probably would have bought
it anyway but still they could have
shared she also needs Tucker he's also
studying I sleep I in West Africa but
they're a little scared of being scooped
because in academia the first person to
publish an idea of finding they get the
credit for it and so they're both
studying so they're kind of in
competition so they don't want to share
too much that's okay oh yeah so weezer's
loss knowledge loss and they could have
shared that data honestly so another
yeah 25k lost magretta it's time to
analyze her data so it's great she has
to data that's hers she didn't share but
she's actually never written code she
did her undergrad in biology where they
memorized taxonomy 'he's they sit in
labs for hours but they never have to
use code so she spends six months
teaching herself python and
bioinformatics just to make some sense
of all this data she has and its immense
amount of data and it's just getting
more and more as our sequencers get
better so both greta and tucker actually
had the same problem and there
independently teaching themselves python
and they write very similar code to run
on their same data sets but no one
actually teaches them that there's a
Python library that does all this for
them they just no one says so because
there are teeth learning by themselves
it's not in their knowledge so yeah
there's software loss because maybe one
of them did it better than the library
but they don't share this with anyone
and then time loss because they had to
spend a lot of time rewriting things
that already exist but Greta does get
some good results from this she realizes
there's a potentially dangerous strain
of s we buy in West African populations
so it's really great its new knowledge
so she can publish this so she does but
um so this is a comic from John
McTiernan his daughter is actually a big
open access advocate he runs like open
conscious one of our community members
but to publish in academia you actually
have to pay to be put in the journal too
little backwards from what we have in
the rest of the world but then also if
you want to pay if you wanted to be an
open access article so if you want it
not to be behind the paywall you have to
pay even more so here and your firstborn
child which is a little crazy and I
think in nature it actually costs about
five thousand dollars to have an open
access journal or an open access article
there and that's far out of the reach
after especially after spending so much
money on sequencing and everything else
but Greta gets published in a
high-impact journal so high impact just
means it's a lot of readers and a lot of
people cite it she's excited so she gets
this prestigious fellowship because she
published first um I didn't put a slide
here but bad news for Tucker he found
the same thing but he's just a few
months too late so he he probably it's
published in a lower impact journal and
he might have a crappier job I'm not
maybe he leaves academia but her
research is actually pay whelped and she
didn't want to pay that extra five
thousand dollars and it's inaccessible
by that West African community that she
studied so they don't take the
preventive measures to handle the
dangerous strain of s flew by and an
outbreak happens there's another comic
by John McTiernan about just what it
feels like to be behind a paywall like
all the research you need is just gone
and separate from you so that was a
fictional story but this happens here's
the couple articles we were warned about
Ebola the recent Ebola outbreak there
were studies behind paywalls that show
that the antibodies for Ebola were
present ten percent of the population
back in the 80s so people really could
have taken these measures long
beforehand but no one who was actually
working there had access to this or knew
about it so it's a real problem today so
we have lost resources what's a software
i guess that's also resource yeah lots
of time and finally loss of lives so I
called this talk the democratization of
science that's why I will fight for
democracy my friend told me to put this
slide in ok where is the open science
today but it's not always like that we
do see open science happening would you
see people collaborating so back to
those earlier problems I showed you
there's the visualizing protein
interactions and open worm data to help
us understand human diseases so um i'm
going to try i didn't marry my screens
let's see if he'll hear ya so this is
where base i used to work for this so
they actually just collect all that
information in C elegans that model
organism I was telling you about earlier
and so many researchers come here to
learn more about what's happening there
and we can see here at sites a zoomin
yeah so this gene here has an ortholog
Inhumans that's a its president
neurodegenerative disease so if we can
see how this gene the protein it codes
no it's gone there yeah we can see how
it interacts so this is
actually using a cytoscape library oh my
screen doesn't like it anyways we can
see how these proteins are interacting
with each other and this might give us
insight into why that disease happens or
yeah how we can help that too back here
so I'll just yeah here's a screenshot of
it since I couldn't show you really but
that helps helps you search a lot here's
a quote about Warren base so that worm
base is the glue that holds a CL iggins
research community together many in
their fields start the day with a cup of
coffee and warm base form anywhere Bay
stays open all day on their computers a
constant companion there's simply no
more efficient way to integrate all the
new data generated in the field so this
is actually from a grant proposal so
it's a bit biased but a lot of people do
use a warm base and that's working on
this project actually made me realize
how important is to just do something
with open data because these researchers
they didn't really know how to code but
just making those visualizations really
helps them they're able to have insights
and produce something another problem so
the second one I mentioned was analyzing
open genetic data to better understand
how virus and bacteria interact this is
a fun story I like actually it's about
one of our community members Madeline
she's in the the top left that that when
is her face so she's actually a grad
student very similar to Greta I guess
but she actually got um she had open
data given to her when she started her
master's student or her master studies
so she didn't have to go and find it um
but she realized that yet she doesn't
know python at all and she didn't know
pearl or how to analyze her data so we
worked with her um just to put together
an open source project as she was
learning and over time community members
a lot of people were interested in
helping or this project you can see in
the participants who number members were
helping teach her things and they told
her about biopython a library that does
a lot of things she spent the first six
months trying to replicate they um yeah
they told him anything so tools like
this are really common for human data
but not as common for bacterial data so
a lot of people are interested in
creating tools that will just analyze
this data
so another thing we do at the science
lab is just run sprints or hackathons
where we bring these scientific projects
together and it's ask people to work on
them so she was here and actually max
from cytoscape the library that created
this visualization they were both there
and it was cool because I worked
together and they actually max came over
and actually made a visualization
showing how the bacteria and the virus
were interacting so it was really yeah
it was really cool how they could do
this together so here's a pathway
Madeleine put together it's a lot of
data munging and honestly it's a lot of
just like format changing and all the
steps that are needed for for analyzing
this data and for someone who's never
liked someone like Madeline who wasn't
used to the command line or we had
different like tools it was really
daunting but for you guys that's nothing
you can change file formats okay the
third problem I talked about earlier was
collecting creating open astronomy
datasets to facilitate data analysis and
discovery so this is a project with
Dimitri muna think he's that oh I forgot
races he's an astronomer somewhere in
the US but he made trillion and the
problem in a strong me today is that um
we have these huge datasets but no one
university can hold all of them so these
astronomers run their experiments and
they put their data up on their
University website but it's hard to do
an analysis across all the open data
that there is there so here's an excerpt
from Dimitri's project astronomy
produces extremely large datasets from
ground-based telescopes space missions
and simulations the problem is that no
one institution can host all this data
let alone have the resources to properly
manage it the result is that applying
analysis against full data sets across
the wide range of wavelengths available
as either beyond the resources of most
astronomers or currently impossible
trillian will make this simple and
straightforward so he's actually working
on yeah he's trying to set up set us up
so distributed systems can go and you
can run and analysis across the
different datasets and yeah from a
central spot and all the strong murs
would do is put up a method and some
queries and then it would give them
their analysis and that would be so
beneficial to astronomers but he's
actually looking for volunteers to help
him he I think he's waiting out for an
astronomer who knows code really well
but I think there's probably someone
here in this audience who's always
wanted to be an astronomer and he's
willing to learn all the details and
context is needed so that they can build
this so here's I yeah this is an image
that do meet you put up there's a data
center compute clusters anyways so there
are many more problems like this and I
do want to encourage you guys to jump
into these projects it's not gonna be
easy it might feel like this sometimes
the scientists aren't used to talking to
people outside of their field and they
like using jargon a lot sorry oh that's
very distracting but it's really funny
though okay but yeah I think you guys
can help a lot so these are people I
told their stories I used the work that
they were doing um but I hope that you
guys like science and are excited about
what we can do together with science so
the slightest science is for everyone so
you guys go to Mozilla science or
explant ear it'll actually ask you a few
questions and just prompt you to go to a
project thats related to what you're
actually interested in doing or you can
go to the Mozilla sign / collaborate
just to see all the projects that we're
helping so one of the big programs we
were doing is just talking to scientists
and just helping them run their projects
open source or learn how to use the
community so I yeah if you guys jump
into these projects sometimes they might
not answer you well or they might not be
the best at welcoming you to their
project but please please try hard
science scientists are learning so you
can teach them a lot about how to work
openly and especially if you haven't
worked in an open source project before
I think this is a great opportunity to
do something meaningful and just to
volunteer your time and something that's
not not super hard but it's very
interesting problems I think this is a
good place so thank you I think that's
all I had
were there any questions yes
mm-hmm
yeah yeah so I think your question was
your friend works at the EPN you're
wondering howdy how to have them reach
out morons like scientific communication
yeah so I think there's been a lot going
on with like Twitter and blogs and
scientists are getting much better at
communicating the research as they're
doing it I'm instead of just hiding it
until they publish but I think a lot of
it you it's a mindset change they have
to realize that it's it's better if
other people hear about it or if the
public hears about it because a lot of
researchers there they're happy just
doing their science publishing and then
just letting the journalists read the
paper and try to translate that back to
the common folk but I think we can
directly speak to humans let's go
there's a TED talk called talk dirty to
me the trains people specifically to I
actually haven't read seen that so i'll
for sure check that out yeah any more
questions yeah back there Oh on the
couch
yeah so is there a lot of pushback from
universities to make research public and
sometimes there is I'm not going to lie
but other times they see that working
with other universities at least is very
beneficial or there's a lot of citizen
science projects going on so see they
can see that engaging the public to
generate data for them or collect data
for them is really good so I think
they're starting to be a shift I think a
lot of the pushback it's more yeah more
from seeing you people are more from
people scared of getting scooped or
worried about getting those high impact
publications I think that's what's
holding a lot of people back but yeah a
lot of people have been collaborating
with us which is cool to build things
all right is there anything else yeah
yeah yeah yeah so why can't researchers
just publish to the web some of them are
and it's great but a lot of them if you
want to get that like prestigious tenure
track or the fellowship you need to show
that you you have these high impact
publications in nature or these other
places so it's hard some people are able
to do it without those publications yeah
so there actually is a journal called
the journal brief ideas which is just
like run on github i think it was made
by arfin smith and stuart something oh
man yes but it's just on the web and you
just publish your brief idea and it goes
online and then you get a DUI for it so
you can cite it so you can say that this
was my idea i should have credit for it
so the building tools like that that are
making it easier to use it's very much
what we're trying to do with the science
lab we're also working on a badges
project because sometimes you have those
um those papers where you have hundreds
of authors and you don't know who did
what so this way we're trying to issue
badges to the author based on what they
actually did so this author wrote the
paper this other dude data analysis so
it's a way of getting credit um more
than just the actual like the impact
factor of the paper but saying that I
did data analysis on these five things
it's meaningful and it shows that you
have a skill I think there's another
question yeah yep
yeah so plus um actually that's a fairly
high impact journal and it is open yeah
it is open access it does cost money
more than a closed access usually um but
there are ways you can get that paid for
it yeah thurs I actually haven't
published in plos I'm not sure all the
details but um yeah it does cost money
there are some other completely open
access i think the prj you pay a
one-time three hundred dollar fee and
then you can publish their as much as
you like but it has a lower impact
factor so it's a trade-off yeah yes
mmhmm yeah so the questions do dis the
mozilla science actually help at all
with storing the data and we don't right
now um that is a good point when I
worked at the enterance suit for cancer
research someone in my lab was trying to
replicate an analysis that was done they
had to download like a petabyte of data
from the UK over here to Canada and then
but it was it was compact then they had
to unzip it so they actually needed like
to head of AIDS of disk space to do this
and like that is not feasible for your
average researcher to do so it is hard
but people are there are a lot of
efforts especially with like genomic
data I think there's like the cancer
collaboratory that's uploading all of
these anonymized cancer data sets where
researchers will be able to just upload
their analysis code and then it will run
on there and then they get results back
so we're not working specifically with
that but we are part of that space
helping people yeah all right any more
questions cool see ya thanks for coming
I feel free to come talk to me I've
spent most of the past two days making
these slides so I'm like a little
socially deprived so I'm willing I I'm
ready to talk to people I'm free now
thank you so much